[Music]
the status of those in attendance said
much about who madeleine albright was
and what she accomplished in life
current and former presidents and vice
presidents secretaries of state cabinet
members congress and diplomats and
politicians from around the world
celebrating the life of the former u.s
ambassador to the united nations and
then the first female secretary of state
a fierce advocate for women in national
security she didn't just help other
women
she spent her entire life counseling and
cajoling
inspiring and lifting up so many of us
who are here today
her work remembered as a hawkish
proponent of u.s military power pushing
her then boss bill clinton to take
action in kosovo she tried to stick up
for people who were left out and left
behind and
in spite of all of its imperfections and
we all know them
i'm very grateful that the peace is held
in bosnia for now
more than 26 years
madeleine was a big part of the reason
nato was still strong
and galvanized
as it is today
madeleine never minced words or wasted
time
when she saw something needed fixing
or someone
who needed helping
but she was also controversial among
other things pushing for tough sanctions
on iraq that critics say led to children
dying of hunger and medicine shortages
we have heard that a half a million
children have died is the price worth it
i think this is a very hard choice but
the price we think the price is worth it
[Music]
still here she was remembered by those
who knew her best as a diplomat mentor
author and mother and all that she
accomplished
much of the focus was on what a truly
remarkable life madeleine albright led
first fleeing europe twice
coming to the united states eventually
rising to the top position the first
woman secretary of state a leader in
national security and foreign policy
that lasted for decades she died at the
age of 84. patty culhane al jazeera
washington